all right well uh
i'm here but noel's late so um guess we
got to kill some time
um actually no i do have one thing to
say though while he's not here uh and
it's just us i want to get this off my
chest all right he's always talking
about f1 right he's always going on and
on about f1 so i decided i'll try and
watch it so i watched the race this
weekend see if i could get into it
i gotta be honest all right
f1
is mid
i'm sorry it's mid it's mid
what was up with the red bull cars just
dying
like in the last three laps the [ __ ] is
it what kind of what kind of [ __ ]
sport is this
that the one thing these cars have to do
they just stop doing it right before the
end of the race
what is that they don't make soccer
balls that don't kick
you know what i mean
basketballs they don't just stop
bouncing in the middle of the [ __ ] i
mean am i right people it's mid
what is
what is this what's going on what's
happening
ryan
no
no no see that
that
is a lot of smoke
coming from a guy that doesn't
drive
okay
what are you doing what what is this
tell me
what is it like knowing that
you have
opinions that are only
wrong
they're not all wrong
right are they
yeah you just gotta pull it just pull it
you gotta really go just yeah it just
yep
may i
yep
that's
what we're here for but yeah go ahead
you see
for a guy like you that does
so much talking
i would think some of it would be at
least
entertaining
all i said
is f1 is mid i feel like this is a
little bit dramatic no
no
okay
you say it's mid
but guys like you
you don't know what you actually believe
because you're a liar
what i tend to do with a fellow like
yourself is i
introduce a little
chaos
and that
tends to get
the real you
do you want to see a magic trick
not really
watch how i make this all
go away
what focus
what is he gonna do
all right big man on your feet
forward
these ropes were hard hey hey hey
on your knees
hey hey go easy on him
like you don't have conviction
no are you good
all i have to do
all i have to do is introduce a little
bit of chaos
a little bit of danger and
it all goes away
what are you doing
i have to come back here
it'll be worse
what are you doing what are you doing
with that
violence
oh one second
oops
it's in here somewhere
i always tell myself you gotta plan
these things better
huh it's not good to have violence in
the first
few minutes of the video
oh yeah true
that's true algebra doesn't like that
uh oh
time's up
oh
what's wrong cody i never dent hurt the
old plaque right
hey hey what you don't want to mess with
me i don't know what i'm capable of
you know what they call me
what
i'm the joker baby hey i'm a pee in this
guy's mouth if he doesn't like my race
car stuff pull out the old calzone cut a
hole in the front and just let it
hey batman you better not mess with me i
got a tummy gum